[Música]
afinal o que é o trabalho infantil
trabalho infantil é toda forma de
trabalho realizada por crianças e
adolescentes abaixo da idade mínima
permitida que no brasil é de 16 anos o
adolescente também pode trabalhar a
partir dos 14 anos de idade mas sem
deixar a escola isso é a lei do aprendiz
que a gente vai falar um pouquinho mais
tarde porque a criança não deve
trabalhar
a criança não deve trabalhar pois seus
únicos deveriam estudar e brincar fora
isso mas né
e essa é uma curiosidade que 1.750
crianças com menos de 12 anos trabalha
na cidade e na zona rural de montes
claros e agora vou passar houve um vídeo
para vocês entenderem melhor sabe a lei
do aprendiz direito para adolescentes
acima de 14 anos com garantias
trabalhistas segurança remuneração eo
melhor sem deixar de estudar hoje no
brasil 60% dos jovens entre 14 e 17 anos
que trabalham exercem atividades ilegais
e perigosas principalmente na indústria
e na agricultura
mas isso não precisa ser assim a lei do
aprendiz que combina a educação e
qualificação do trabalho
você não deve abandonar a escola pelo
trabalho
os programas de aprendizagem é possível
ter um futuro do planeta e garantido
[Música]
porque escolhi esse tema é que esse
tempo aqui na minha casa nossa gigante
foi vítima no trabalho infantil desde os
cinco anos de idade até a adolescência
onde ela tinha que trabalhar para ajudar
a família e sustentar os irmãos
o gráfico a seguir mas é quantas
crianças sofrem por causa do trabalho
infantil de 5 a 13 anos são em média 6%
e de 14 e 17 anos em média 10%
como podemos ajudar
sabemos que o trabalho infantil não
acontece lá dentro de casa
acontece também nas ruas infelizmente
onde podemos ver facilmente as crianças
vendendo doces sacos panos de chão mas
você não pode comprar
se você comprar elas vão entender que
ela tem que continuar e vão receber
dinheiro em troca
você também pode ficar sem se ver uma
criança nessa situação a ligação é
gratuita coube a atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]